whatever the American perspective your
opinion you really won't say no I'm I'm
saying it's like one it's once uh one
country two systems you know
no it's not it's two different countries
really Taiwan and China is that
according to American foreign what's
your opinion you love China I I think
China China so much why don't you marry
it
Hassan wants everyone in Taiwan to be
because he loves China he's a Xi Jinping
that's what I heard the next day oh boy
Ethan Club been getting canceled by his
own fans well the thing that I didn't
appreciate is just how crazy
and insulting and like just insane
people got because I dared to be a
Social Democrat and not a full-blown
socialist I was called a class Trader
I'm not radical enough for you then
you've got no allies zero you have zero
allies you labeled us what a Centrist a
right-wing operative why because we
didn't agree with you on certain topics
you just got client
you got climbed by your own people my
guy they said something they said oh
look at these centrists and they went
air quotes they're centrists you know
yeah yeah and we know what that means
kind of um people look at you it's not
that you're an imperfect Ally you're
just an enemy Ethan Klein's been having
some disagreements with Hassan [__] on
their podcast The Leftovers on the
topics of socialism versus capitalism so
him and Hassan have this podcast right
and they've been butting heads what do
you think's been doing this thing you
know I mean as as a you know as a solid
hater yeah how about like oh
some arguments like very sound very
balanced you're not a hater then
if you're able to do that you're not a
hater no I'm a hater no there's some
things you hate no no I'm a hater yeah
like I just have to find one thing I
hate and then I just drag that [__] as
long as I can to really enjoy the hate
your pity yeah that's not like uh that's
one of the tenets of the player player
haters Club Fair be Petty and if you
pass an oof degree then you part of the
club
[Music]
he wants to like fight against China but
he also kind of wants to like leave
Taiwan to China it's like very weird how
do we feel about Taiwan Hassan China or
not Taiwan or is it China or not China
that's the American policy whatever the
American policy is whatever the American
perspective opinion you really won't say
no I'm I'm saying it's like one it's
once uh one country two systems you know
no it's not it's two different countries
really Taiwan and China is that
according to American foreign what's
your opinion
what's your opinion Taiwan independent
my opinion on Taiwan is that Taiwan is
uh the the the Chinese
concept of Taiwan
no no
I really thought it was me I I really I
thought I listened to that and I thought
Papa
Hassan is talented at using a lot of
words to say nothing and then look at
you like you're the idiot for not
understanding the fact that he said
nothing bro I really thought I was
having a stroke I'm like why am I not
understanding what the [__] is saying yo
shout out to Ethan's like yo what's your
opinion uh you know America is one
country but no no what's your opinion
should remain uh in the hands of the
people in Taiwan who art independent who
for the for the record for the most part
just believed to not disrupt the ongoing
uh the ongoing relations uh why are you
being so carefully footed around because
I know that there's going to be a
celebrity there's going to be a
celebrity post with like a million
[__] comments being like Hassan wants
everyone in Taiwan to be because he
loves China he's a Xi Jinping that's
what I heard
that's what everybody heard just say
your foot say what you see see this is a
problem with hopes right now they become
so scared of the reaction to whatever
action they're about to take that they
don't take any action he said nothing
because he knew if he said something it
would get a reaction that's all he was
terrified about and I'm like brev you're
a political commentator I could
understand it from the regular man this
is your goddamn job that's your money
but this dude wants to rub hands with
people and be so diplomatic all the time
that's why people kind of look at him
he's like he's a big phony he's just so
concerned with the perception of
everything he does when his job is to
take political stances you're not a
politician you're a political
commentator do your job and even Ethan
who's that's not a job he's like taking
the stronger stance he's like stop being
a coward that's what that's what I just
it's already over you ask that question
it like ingests and it's gonna no I was
genuinely curious what you think about
it
um I think
that overall it's a it's
it's contemporary history is complex at
the end of the day if the Taiwanese
citizens uh would ever put this up for a
vote and were like we want to [__] be
an independent nation it's up to them
you know what I mean
uh no there's not no what Hassan said is
true from everything I've read that most
most people in Taiwan nowadays support
just keeping the status quo yeah they
probably do because they saw what
happened to Hong Kong they probably do
because they don't want China to Barrel
in because they know nobody gonna stop
them if you being honest most countries
want to be their independent they don't
want to have to be dependent but they
also don't want to see their family
members get murked they don't want to
see their whole Villages get raced to
the ground so the acquiesce oh yeah most
want why do they want to maintain a
status quo is it because they're happy
being part of China or is it because
they don't want to disappear
like the original Inception of the
country is Taiwan a
fascist dictatorship that America
recognizes the real china until Richard
Nixon uh normalized relations with China
and that's where they implemented the uh
they call it strategic ambiguity which I
call lying strategic ambiguity you mean
what you're doing when you're trying to
answer a question
Taiwan is already independent that's
what I'm saying people don't want a
formal declaration just because they
don't want a [__] War
but they I'm they're not wanting to be
Hong Kong can get be real like consumed
by the Chinese
party you don't want to be Hong Kong
what's what happened in Hong Kong
am I stay in the right place no you but
overall if you look at the situation of
Hong Kong right now it's it's like they
claimed that it was going to be
devastating and that has not happened
not that we know of because they can't
fight they have no freedom of speech
anymore
okay they can't talk that part is true
you're right having said that
you can just go to Hong Kong and you can
just go to every part of China pretty
much and see for yourself this is no
longer like the uh the north korea-style
hermit Kingdom we're like I don't think
anybody's saying it's North Korea
they're just saying it's really really
[__] it's not because it's like when
you know some dudes beating his wife and
you're like no they're fine you can go
there for dinner and everything's calm
She's Not Dead
I didn't see any bruises on her yeah
because he punches the tick and the body
where nobody sees it we have a a
regardless we have a [__] ton of Chinese
people that live in America regardless
bro it's not that in China they had
rights they don't have rights now they
lost a lot of Rights but whatever I mean
you're you're this is interesting that
you're very soft you're very uh
you're very um
soft footed around the issue of China
you love China I I
think China you love China so much why
don't you marry it
tell my childish if you don't if you're
a fan of so much why don't you suck your
dick
yo shout out to Eva this is the most
based he's been in a long time this is a
Dashi no that's a lie Hammond just
probably think is also great but this is
amazing overall that kind of uh
mechanism of control is is one that I do
not appreciate personally
which is why I choose to live here
but
um as far as uh like cruelty oppression
like what you're talking about with
respect to Hong Kong
um
the the the promises that Western media
overall made about like how China was
going to crush Hong Kong under its like
ruthless oppressive thumbs
I don't think that was the point I think
the point was just that there's
whoever was you know vocal about
wanting to maintain certain rights in
Hong Kong was probably thrown in a
secret prison and never heard from again
I mean certainly there was political
dissidents are definitely hey hey shout
out to Eva I gotta give him some credit
I'm not gonna give subscribe okay all
we got a Discord we got a Reddit yo
links in the description below go check
them out otherwise we also have a video
editing contest we're hiring an editor
if you want to be part of it go to and
basically edit your own video of apple
and preach upload it to tick tock right
with the caption admin Preach video
contest uh and uh from there
go check you out we might hire you on
full time remote job let's go great one
I know that I'm a capitalist and so I've
been trying to think like how do you
square that with my other like socialist
ideas Socialist Communist uh uh idea
that people want is like just a pipe
dream yeah I don't really
do you really want to get into this
right now I don't mind
essentially what I'm asking is do you
think democracy is a good thing and do
you think democracy is what helps
prevent yeah so
what if we ran companies that way
because companies aren't democracies
they're totalitarian first of all
usually how come how are companies made
usually
um are you saying like like an
entrepreneur starts a small business
like apple let's just take Apple or
Google right it's made by three four
people Apple uh and over the years it's
growing it's growing
and so how do you run Apple at what
point does it become like subject to
public opinion on who's going to run it
that's just like that at what point does
it get big enough to make a good
question on the discussion now where
they start debating the merits of
socialism versus capitalism right and
the fan base loses it
fan base is like oh Ethan you know they
start going crazy about the fact that
he's pro-capitalism and he has some good
questions like throughout the whole
thing he asked like all right like if
what are we going to take away companies
and just start redistributing it to
everyone like how do you guys want this
to happen and it's like some good
questions
and then
he posted something
yeah obviously Friday was uh kind of
crazy I'm gonna talk about it I know if
I should talk about it tomorrow on
Thursday because I want to talk with
Hassan and Dan about it I have more
questions I have a thirst for knowledge
as you guys know I am a you know I'm
just a voracious learner and I care
about the people I have questions well
the thing that I didn't appreciate is
just how crazy
and insulting and like just insane
people got because I dared to be a
Social Democrat and not a full-blown
socialist
and so to some people that was I was
called a class Trader I guess I'm not
radical enough for you then you're
they're you've got no allies zero you
have zero allies if 95 of the country is
not more radical than me I guarantee
that he feels bothered by the fact that
people are calling him a traitor just
for disagreeing on some points I
understand the feeling absolutely I
remember a time when I disagreed with
Ethan and he called me a Centrist or a
right winger all because I didn't agree
with everything he had to say in regards
to the left they said something they
said oh look at these centrists and they
went air quotes they're centrists you
know yeah yeah and we know what that
means kind of um when they say when they
say strangers like this with oh yeah
that's what you're saying they're trying
to say they're not actually they're
saying we're right right yeah yeah
you're right the irony of this whole
thing is that politically speaking we
have way more in common with these two
people than we would with anyone on the
right right people look at you it's not
that you're an imperfect Ally you're
just an enemy the moment you disagree
you're not like an ally who I disagree
with you're not like this person on the
same team who we just have a different
Vision to some degree you're an enemy
immediately yeah please do not take
these political conversations so
personally
we can call the class Trader a thousand
times because I'm only a Social Democrat
and not a full socialist makes me not
want to have combos like this anymore
which is probably the least productive
outcome
um funny
very funny that you say that because I
think it's whack that people are doing
that whatever but that's what you do
that's you
that is a hundred percent you and the
people that are following you you
labeled us what a Centrist a right-wing
operative why because we didn't agree
with you on certain topics now all of a
sudden you disagree with your fan base
on something a little bit political and
you get cast aside as some [__]
bigger or whatever it is that they're
calling you right now right it's just
interesting how that mirror you just got
kind
you got climbed by your own people my
guy like that's that's what you do that
is a hundred percent what you do
absolutely whenever we don't agree with
something and then after that you're
gonna do some uh you're gonna do some
intellectual uh shortcuts
not watch videos and make your opinion
on so at least they saw what at least at
least the people that are calling you a
traitor and this and that and whatever
actually listen to what you said and
then called you that you on the other
hand what you do is you go on calling
people whatever not watching their
content
you're worse than these people they
actually listen to you my guy today
I'm not gonna be Petty
this is what I will say I'm not
we made that video before what we said
was uh
we can't be an imperfect Ally we have to
be the enemy I think that's like the
title of the video we talked about how
we felt very ostracized politically from
the left because of people like Ethan
Klein a lot of these people who've
co-opted
um but leftists right
and who routinely kick people out for
not agreeing with everything yes now
you're going through the same treatment
I'm not going to wish it on you even
though it feels kind of good on the
inside low-key I do think it's whack
because at the end of the day I do think
you were advocating for positions that
made sense and that were strong and it's
a shame that they weren't even open to
that and they were convinced so much
that they had the right idea that they
immediately went to Mock and laugh at
you right or to ostracize you or to call
you names I think that's whack person uh
because beyond my Petty feelings I do
think a lot of what you're saying right
now makes a lot of sense to me as well
um
yeah hopefully you don't stop talking
about these things because I think
you're fostering an audience that is
becoming more radical in terms of
socialist ideas and it's good to have a
bit of balance in terms of a voice
that's different and that's just some
Echo chamber to be like redistribute the
wealth bro I think it's good to have
people involved who feel differently and
share that perspective I don't care
you created and you fostered these
people and then you made them grow into
this
and now they turn on you that's just you
you was a parasite that made other
parasites and now those parasites are
chomping on you that's what you did
you want to give 10 more metaphors for
the same thing I got I got a couple of
more why
that's what you did so I don't really
care I'm not wishing on you I don't have
to wish it on you it's happening
it's going to pass but it's happening it
was about to happen and I hope this is a
good lesson to everybody watching it's
not a lesson to nobody nobody no I think
there is a real lesson I think I think
there's people who are watching who are
taking this in okay there's plenty of
viewers who are like oh wait I I do
think this behavior is kind of crazy and
sometimes it's not happened it doesn't
it's not until it happens to Creator or
person close to you or someone that you
really like that you realize like oh
[__] this might be a problem so
hopefully everybody takes this in let's
let's let's be careful understand what
you're saying but I'm just saying you
created this uh
but then again but then again you're
gonna do all of that and I'm gonna be
like oh well I have a little bit of
symphony I'm like and man you don't have
to have sympathy nobody asks you to have
to have people you don't have to you do
whatever you want you want to be Petty
be Petty I do it that's not even that's
not that is absolutely if you're not
advocating for what is right in the
moment or for the positions that are
correct because you said well you get
what you get that's fine that's fine but
you're not advocating for the world that
you actually want to see I'm not saying
I'm not saying that's not I'm not I'm
saying I'm not being petty I understand
I understand what he's saying and he is
he is right on some point I got that but
the fact that you go at least the people
please listen to you
and they don't agree and not I'm like
yeah it's supposed to happen that's what
you want I and I think all of those two
all those things can coexist
I don't think it should happen to you
but here we are and
yeah you can get it maybe you agree with
me maybe you're gonna preach maybe you
agree with both it's okay the end of the
day you're never going to see me being
out here being like Oh no we agree bro I
just include my other side my other side
my my you can get inside maybe we agree
in your head but like what came out of
your mouth was just like petty petty
petty a petty petty petty petty petty
WAP
but I believe that we're actually on the
same point wow yeah
yeah I'm telling you I'm telling you I
agree with which everything you're
saying yeah you are right
you can get it
I'm bad like that at any rate all this
to say this was a bit of a longer video
but yes go check it out 81.